This is 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. If there's one sound that instantly transports me back in time, it's this one, the dial-up modem tone. It reminds me of being in grad school in 1994. I was talking to one of my thesis advisors about the worldwide web and how much cool stuff was on there and how distracting it was, and he recommended that I take the weekend to go through
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果有一种声音能瞬间把我带回过去，那就是拨号上网的调制解调器声。它让我想起1994年读研的时候。当时我正和一位论文导师谈论万维网，谈论网上有多少酷东西，以及它有多让人分心，他建议我利用周末时间把整个网络浏览一遍，
the whole thing and get it out of my system. The internet was so new that a person with a PhD thought you could literally finish it in one weekend. For me, the dial-up tone reminds me of being a kid in the early 90s. When I thought the internet was just that thing that my older tech savvy cousins logged on to the L.A.R.E.E. strangers. Now, what's that thing that everyone logs on to the yellow strangers?
把这种瘾戒掉。当时的互联网还很新，以至于一位拥有博士学位的人竟然认为你真的可以在一个周末内把它看完。对我来说，拨号上网的声音让我想起90年代初还是个孩子的时候。那时我以为互联网只是我那些精通技术的表亲们用来登录“L.A.R.E.E.陌生人”的东西。等等，那个每个人都登录的“黄色陌生人”到底是什么？
That's millennial producer Vivian Leigh. It's weird to think about because I, along with probably the rest of you, have been spending about 97% of my waking life on Slack, or Twitter, or Netflix, or Google Docs, but I'm just old enough to remember a time before the internet was a requirement to participate in society. At time before, it was everywhere. It was this new thing that you heard about. I first heard about the internet. This is David Bonette.
那是千禧一代制作人薇薇安·李。想到这一点很奇怪，因为我和你们其他人一样，大概97%的清醒时间都花在Slack、Twitter、Netflix或Google Docs上，但我刚好大到还记得互联网尚未成为社会参与必需品之前的时代。在它无处不在之前，它只是你听说过的一种新事物。我第一次听说互联网是在……这是大卫·博内特。
I was reading a magazine, I think PC World or something like that, And I just thought, oh, this just sounds amazing. Today, David's a philanthropist and tech entrepreneur. But back in the early 1990s, he really wanted to do something great with this thing called the World Wide Web. Because the way he saw it, it was about to change the world for the better. David and his business partner,
当时我正在读一本杂志，我想是《PC World》之类的，我当时就想，噢，这听起来太棒了。如今，大卫是一位慈善家和科技企业家。但在90年代初，他真的很想用这个叫“万维网”的东西做点伟大的事情。因为在他看来，它即将让世界变得更美好。大卫和他的商业伙伴，
a guy named John Resner, decided in order to be a part of this digital revolution, they would found in the internet company that hosted websites. The plan was straightforward enough. David and John would provide the online space and some basic tools so that individuals or companies could build their own web page.
一个叫约翰·雷斯纳的人，决定为了参与这场数字革命，他们要创办一家托管网站的互联网公司。计划很简单。大卫和约翰提供在线空间和一些基础工具，让个人或公司可以建立自己的网页。
And the company would host those pages on its servers. And because their office was based in Beverly Hills, they named their company Beverly Hills Internet. It will go down as having one of the worst names in history. Actually, Beverly Hills Internet was doing OK at first. It was starting to get some visitors to its website. But John and David found it difficult to get the kind of sustainable traffic
公司则将这些页面托管在服务器上。因为他们的办公室设在比佛利山庄，他们就把公司命名为“比佛利山庄互联网”（Beverly Hills Internet）。这后来被公认为史上最糟糕的名字之一。其实，比佛利山庄互联网起初做得还不错。它的网站开始有一些访问者了。但约翰和大卫发现，很难获得那种可持续的流量，
that they really wanted, mostly because of one huge early 90s problem. What is internet? Internet is that massive computer network. The one that's becoming really big now. What do you mean that's big? How does one know? What do you write to it like mail? Allison, can you explain what internet is? A lot of people didn't really get what internet was. Nobody really understood at the time what it meant to create a worldwide web of these kinds of connections where all computers
这主要是因为90年代初的一个巨大难题。什么是互联网？互联网是那个巨大的计算机网络。就是现在变得非常大的那个。你说的“大”是什么意思？怎么知道它大？你是像写信一样给它写东西吗？艾莉森，你能解释一下什么是互联网吗？很多人真的不明白什么是互联网。当时没人真正理解建立这种连接的万维网意味着什么，即所有计算机
were talking with one another and sharing information. So I had the challenge both trying to explain to my friends what I was trying to do and the wider world at the same time. Even though today the internet is woven indoor every day lives, it wasn't that long ago that people had to make this enormously from a world with essentially no internet, to trying to conceptualize what a globally connected computer network meant, or what they
都在相互交谈并共享信息。所以我面临着双重挑战：既要向朋友解释我在做什么，又要向更广阔的世界解释。尽管今天互联网已经融入了我们的日常生活，但不久前，人们还不得不从一个基本没有互联网的世界，去尝试构想一个全球互联的计算机网络意味着什么，或者他们
would even do with it? Before search engines like Google, or social networks, or apps, the web seemed like this confusing, nebulous blob of information. It was a strange new technology that was hard to wrap our brains around. Because David Ran in internet company, his business dependent on users, having some grasp of what the internet was. So it was his challenge to get people comfortable on the web. There's got, you know, we need to develop, we need to come up with something more.
甚至能用它做什么？在谷歌等搜索引擎、社交网络或应用程序出现之前，网络看起来就像一个令人困惑、模糊不清的信息团。这是一种很难理解的奇怪新技术。因为大卫经营着一家互联网公司，他的生意依赖于用户对互联网的某种理解。所以他的挑战就是让人们在网上感到舒适。他说，你知道，我们需要开发，我们需要想出更多东西。
They needed a hook. And one day in 1994, it just came to them. His hosting site didn't need a technological innovation. It needed a conceptual one. Users needed a new way of navigating the web. So we sketched out a plan to make his website feel more like a real neighborhood. You'd go through what was a two-dimensional representation of a neighborhood where you would see streets and blocks and you would see icons that represented houses and you would
他们需要一个卖点。1994年的一天，灵感突然降临。他的托管网站不需要技术创新，而是需要概念上的创新。用户需要一种导航网络的新方式。于是，他们草拟了一个计划，让他的网站感觉更像一个真实的社区。你会穿过一个二维的社区表现形式，在那里你会看到街道和街区，你会看到代表房子的图标，你
actually pick an address that you wanted to create your website. And you had a sense that you were joining a neighborhood. David didn't want people to think of the web as something you logged on to, but more like a physical place to dwell in, like a house. When you signed up for a new web page, that web page was your house
实际上可以选择一个你想创建网站的地址。你会有一种加入了一个社区的感觉。大卫不想让人们认为网络是你登录的东西，而更像是一个可以居住的物理场所，就像房子一样。当你注册一个新网页时，那个网页就是你的房子，
in an online community of your choosing. This was all a new frontier and you were in a way of virtual homesteader. David and his team were endowing users with a sense of digital manifest destiny, one virtual neighborhood at a time. It was such a revolutionary idea that David and his partner decided to chuck out the whole Beverly Hills internet name and change their company to something that fully leaned into these spatial metaphor they were creating. They called it geositties. The story of geositties is just a fantastic parallel
在你选择的在线社区中。这完全是一个新领域，你从某种意义上说是一个虚拟的拓荒者。大卫和他的团队正在赋予用户一种数字“昭昭天命”感，一次一个虚拟社区。这是一个如此革命性的想法，以至于大卫和他的合伙人决定抛弃“比佛利山庄互联网”这个名字，将公司改名为一个完全契合他们正在创造的空间隐喻的名字。他们称之为“GeoCities”（地球村）。GeoCities的故事是一个绝佳的平行案例，
for a real building, for something that was conceived of and created to model real life, but in the domain of cyberspace and which ultimately had a catastrophic and dramatic fall in the end. This is James Crawford, the author of Falling Glory, the lives and deaths of history's greatest buildings. Geocities was not a physical place, but he included it in his book because the way he sees it, it was inhabited like one. That was something that I think geosities was really providing, was creating these communities and then conceptualizing them as places.
它就像一座真实的建筑，是为了模拟现实生活而构思和创造的，但却是在网络空间领域，最终却以灾难性和戏剧性的方式陨落。这是詹姆斯·克劳福德，著有《陨落的荣耀：历史上最伟大建筑的生与死》。GeoCities不是一个物理场所，但他把它写进了书里，因为在他看来，它像一个物理场所一样被居住着。我认为GeoCities真正提供的是创造这些社区，并将它们概念化为场所。
As places you could go as neighborhoods on the net. So you could be a citizen of a city, of a country, and you could then be a netizen of somewhere like geosities. The website was a collection of metropolises, each with their own neighborhoods built around shared interests. There was a region called Heartland where you could discuss tractor models or Petsburg where you could talk endlessly about your cats or in Area 51 you could find page after page after page
作为你可以去的场所，作为网上的社区。所以你可以成为一个城市、一个国家的公民，然后你也可以成为像GeoCities这样的地方的“网民”。该网站是多个大都市的集合，每个大都市都有围绕共同兴趣建立的社区。有一个叫“Heartland”（中心地带）的区域，你可以在那里讨论拖拉机模型；或者在“Petsburg”（宠物城），你可以无休止地谈论你的猫；或者在“Area 51”（51区），你可以找到一页又一页
of fan tributes to Dana Scully. As soon as David established this specialized version of the web, Juicities really began to click for people. David remembers how in the early days, he set up a little alert to go off anytime someone registered for a new account. So I'd be sitting in my office and we'll go dang,
关于丹娜·斯嘉丽的粉丝致敬页面。一旦大卫建立了这个专门化的网络版本，GeoCities真的开始吸引人们了。大卫记得在早期，他设置了一个小提醒，每当有人注册新账户时就会响。所以我坐在办公室里，它会发出“叮”的一声，
and someone would say, what's that? And I would say, well, somebody just registered for their own page of juicities and they said, oh, that's cool? And I would say, well, somebody just registered for their own page of geosities. And they said, oh, that's cool. Then it went down. And then it really started to take off. Ultimately, it was just non-stop. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
有人会问，那是什么？我会说，噢，有人刚刚注册了他们自己的GeoCities页面。他们说，噢，那很酷。然后它又响了。然后它真的开始起飞了。最终，它简直是没完没了。叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。
I mean, it was just, it was really, really exciting. You know, I would start to hear like, I mean, this is happening a lot. And so, of course, I had turned it off because it was too disruptive. David wanted users who built their web pages and geocities to feel like part of a community. That no matter how obscure their interests were,
我的意思是，这真的、真的非常令人兴奋。你知道，我开始听到，我的意思是，这种情况发生得很多。所以，当然，我不得不把它关掉，因为它太吵了。大卫希望在GeoCities建立网页的用户能感到自己是社区的一部分。无论他们的兴趣多么冷门，
they could find a neighbor who felt just as passionately as they did about Star Trek or 12th century Norse mythology. I think a lot of that comes from my own experiences as a gay man and coming out and meeting other lesbian and gay people and understanding the power of meeting others of your own identity. I think people came to it with more open minds and less desire to be performative in how they were interact online. It was this fleeting moment when users see more interest in making human connections
他们都能找到一个和他们一样对《星际迷航》或12世纪北欧神话充满热情的邻居。我认为这很大程度上源于我作为一名男同性恋者的个人经历，出柜并结识其他女同性恋者和男同性恋者，并理解结识与你身份相同的人的力量。我认为人们带着更开放的心态来到这里，减少了在网上互动时进行表演的欲望。这是一个短暂的时刻，用户似乎对建立人际联系
and honest self-expression than in cultivating a web persona. They just wanted to build something. They wanted to build something dedicated to Dana Scully. Hahaha. I was looking to give everybody the tools to create their own content and celebrate the terrific diversity, and richness, and tapestry of content created by users. There were, of course, some limitations to user-generated content.
和诚实的自我表达比培养网络人设更感兴趣。他们只是想建立点什么。他们想建立一个专门献给丹娜·斯嘉丽的东西。哈哈。我当时想给每个人提供创建自己内容的工具，并庆祝用户创造的内容所具有的惊人多样性、丰富性和挂毯般的质感。当然，用户生成的内容也有一些局限性。
Geocities was a website that was built by amateurs, and it showed. The color palettes of most geocities pages seemed like they were chosen randomly, or maybe even chosen with the intention of making them illegible, like neon green text over a neon yellow background. There were under construction signs, twinkling star backgrounds, grainy low-res family photos, welcome to my homepage gifs,. Or GIFs of Dancing Babies. You know, it was the Wild West, just different styles and different page layouts and different menus, bars and even, you know, experimenting with menus and pages that were only menus.
GeoCities是一个由业余爱好者建立的网站，这一点显而易见。大多数GeoCities页面的配色方案看起来像是随机选择的，甚至可能是为了让人看不清而选择的，比如霓虹黄背景上的霓虹绿文字。到处都是“施工中”标志、闪烁的星星背景、颗粒感十足的低分辨率家庭照片、欢迎来到我的主页的GIF，或者跳舞婴儿的GIF。你知道，那是蛮荒西部，只是不同的风格、不同的页面布局、不同的菜单栏，甚至，你知道，尝试使用只有菜单的页面。
There was an absolute session with Comic-Songs font, you know, all these kind of things, flashing GIFs. comic songs, font, you know, all these kind of things, flashing gifts, all these things that are almost feel like a kind of early vomitus of the internet. Looking back to the lands of the flat design and minimalism that came after, it's hard to click through these pages without having a chuckle. It was a whole lot messier and much more chaotic,
当时有一种对Comic Sans字体的绝对痴迷，你知道，所有这些东西，闪烁的GIF。Comic Sans字体，你知道，所有这些东西，闪烁的GIF，所有这些感觉几乎像是互联网早期呕吐物的东西。回顾后来出现的扁平化设计和极简主义，不笑出声来很难点击这些页面。它要混乱得多，也嘈杂得多，
but the pages built on Geosities reflected this amazing moment when people were attempting to figure out what the internet was and what it could be. It's this beginning of the creation of web culture and that's what's so interesting. It's the beginning of Paris, the website. It's translating your life who you are and putting it online. By 1998, Geosities was the third most visited website on the internet, just after Yahoo. In fact, Yahoo was so impressed with Geosities' rapid ascent that they bought the company from David. Executives at Geosities believed that combining forces with Yahoo would put the website
但建立在GeoCities上的页面反映了这样一个惊人的时刻：人们试图弄清楚互联网是什么，以及它能成为什么。这是网络文化创造的开端，这才是最有趣的地方。这是巴黎，这个网站的开端。它在翻译你的生活，你是谁，并把它放到网上。到1998年，GeoCities是互联网上访问量第三大的网站，仅次于雅虎。事实上，雅虎对GeoCities的迅速崛起印象深刻，以至于他们从大卫手中买下了这家公司。GeoCities的高管们相信，与雅虎强强联手会让网站
on steroids. But that wasn't what most geocities users wanted. Users had legitimate concerns that, you know, geocities will lose its independence and its identity, which is ultimately what happened. After the purchase, geocities users woke up to a notice saying they had to re-register, granting Yahoo the rights to? The wealthy free, perpetual, irrevocable, non-exclusive, and fully sub-licensable rights and lessons to use, re-brews, modify, adapt, publish, translate, create derivative works
如虎添翼。但那并不是大多数GeoCities用户想要的。用户有合理的担忧，你知道，GeoCities会失去它的独立性和身份，而这最终也确实发生了。收购后，GeoCities用户醒来时收到通知，说他们必须重新注册，授予雅虎以下权利：免费、永久、不可撤销、非排他性且可完全分许可的权利和许可，以在全球范围内使用、复制、修改、改编、发布、翻译、创作衍生作品、
from, distribute, perform, and display such content in whole or part worldwide and or to incorporate it in other works in any form, media or technology, now known or later developed. Meaning all of the content on the website would now be owned by Yahoo. Many threatened to leave the city in protest, and as a result of that Yahoo actually agreed to alter their
分发、表演和展示此类内容，全部或部分，和/或将其纳入其他任何形式、媒体或技术中，无论是现在已知还是以后开发的。这意味着网站上的所有内容现在都归雅虎所有。许多人威胁要抗议离开这个城市，结果雅虎确实同意修改他们的
fingers that one day they'd be profitable. There was actually a mantra that you weren't a successful.com company unless you were losing money. By the year 2001, the bubble had burst, in corporations like Yahoo, we're losing their footing. The internet was starting to change fast. Up until this point, a lot of users had been working in a static entry-level version of the internet. It was more homemade, identifiable by those vibrant,
指望有一天能盈利。当时甚至有一种口号，如果你不亏钱，你就不是一家成功的.com公司。到了2001年，泡沫破裂，像雅虎这样的公司开始站不稳脚跟。互联网开始迅速改变。直到这一点，许多用户一直在一个静态的入门级互联网版本中工作。它更像家庭作坊，以那些充满活力的、
personal pages hand-built by users. It's where geosities had drived. But by the time the new millennium rolled around, the internet was evolving into a whole new experience. This internet was based around interactive social networking sites. You would punch in your name, age, and relationship status, and the site would spit out a manicured profile page. Users were encouraged to write on each other's walls and tag and comment. Geocities had created this great spatial metaphor to help people understand the web, but users were outgrowing that metaphor. Having a Geocities page began to feel embarrassing to a lot of users, which is basically a death sentence for any platform.
由用户手工制作的个人页面为标志。这就是GeoCities蓬勃发展的地方。但当新千年到来时，互联网正在演变成一种全新的体验。这个互联网是围绕交互式社交网站建立的。你输入你的名字、年龄和关系状态，网站就会吐出一个精心修饰的个人资料页面。用户被鼓励在彼此的墙上留言、标记和评论。GeoCities创造了这个伟大的空间隐喻来帮助人们理解网络，但用户已经超越了那个隐喻。拥有一个GeoCities页面开始让许多用户感到尴尬，这对任何平台来说基本上都是死刑判决。
I can't shake up my geo-city's account. Hold on. Eee-eee-eee. Ah. Let me crank up the computer. Let me get a phone. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no I suppose because we're so close to it and we know the people who created these. Maybe there are parents, maybe there are older brothers or sisters and we don't necessarily respect it.
我无法摆脱我的GeoCities账户。等等。咿-咿-咿。啊。让我启动电脑。让我找个电话。不，不，不……我想是因为我们离它太近了，我们认识创造这些东西的人。也许是父母，也许是哥哥姐姐，我们不一定尊重它。
Yahoo! Stocks started to plummet shortly after a bot geocities and year after year the site was losing more users. From a business perspective, Geocities seemed like dead weight. July 2009, they sent what they call a service announcement. And all it says is that Geocities is closing and all files are going to be deleted from servers and will not be recoverable.
雅虎的股票在收购GeoCities后不久就开始暴跌，网站的用户一年比一年少。从商业角度来看，GeoCities看起来像个累赘。2009年7月，他们发布了所谓的“服务公告”。上面只写着GeoCities即将关闭，所有文件都将从服务器上删除，且无法恢复。
Geocities was about to be completely wiped out as if it had never existed. You know, even if you look at something like the dropping of a nuclear bomb, that still leaves ruins, it still leaves people, you know, those people can then grow something from the ashes. This is an absolute existential deletion of existence. You know, it has just taken and it is gone. This was the whole sale destruction of a website that changed the way that people looked at the internet.
GeoCities即将被彻底抹去，仿佛它从未存在过。你知道，即使你看看像投下原子弹这样的事情，它仍然会留下废墟，仍然会留下人，你知道，那些人可以从灰烬中成长。这是一种绝对的、存在主义的删除。你知道，它就这样被拿走了，消失了。这是对一个改变了人们看待互联网方式的网站的全面摧毁。
A lot of people believe that these pages deserve to be saved. And a handful of people decided to actually do something about it. There's this sense always that like the web is permanent. Like if you do something terrible, it's on the internet forever. And if you have one embarrassing photo and someone shares it, it'll never go away. And I'm here to tell you that now it'll probably all go away.
很多人认为这些页面值得被保存。少数人决定真正为此做点什么。人们总有一种感觉，认为网络是永久的。好像如果你做了什么可怕的事，它就会永远留在互联网上。如果你有一张尴尬的照片，有人分享了它，它就永远不会消失。但我在这里告诉你，现在它很可能会全部消失。
This is Jason Scott. Jason actually has a few roles. He's a digital archivist, historian, software curator, angel of death. So the reason I'm known as the angel of death is because I have successfully let people know that when a certain kind of situation happens, call Jason Scott.
这是杰森·斯科特。杰森其实有几个角色。他是数字档案管理员、历史学家、软件策展人、死亡天使。所以我被称为“死亡天使”的原因是，我成功地让人们知道，当某种情况发生时，给杰森·斯科特打电话。
The situation is that a website is on the brink of its demise, and all of its digital information is about to be lost forever. Jason's job is to swoop in and download all of that data before it's gone for good. And like the angel of death, Jason's face is the last thing that a dying website sees before it's gone for good. Back in 2009, before he became the go-to savior of the old web, Jason was noticing more and more that old school hosting services like Geocities were going dark. He couldn't stop thinking about all the user-generated content that was being destroyed in the process.
这种情况就是某个网站濒临倒闭，其所有数字信息都将永远丢失。杰森的工作是在它彻底消失之前冲进去下载所有数据。就像死亡天使一样，杰森的脸是垂死的网站在彻底消失前看到的最后一样东西。早在2009年，在他成为旧网络的首选救星之前，杰森就越来越多地注意到像GeoCities这样的老派托管服务正在变暗。他无法停止思考在这个过程中被摧毁的所有用户生成内容。
The one that still haunts me is this woman who in 1994 made an entire website in HTML about her child who had died when he was two, and she's got a little, you know, candle gif and a little midi song playing in the background, and this was her story. Jason wanted to make sure sites like Jews, in their data, weren't just erased. So we connected with a group of like-minded digital preservation enthusiasts scattered around the world, and they drafted a plan. Somebody should come in, there should be an A-Team, an archive team that rushes in and makes a copy. Wouldn't that be something? So we announced that we're an archive team.
最让我难以忘怀的是一位女士，她在1994年用HTML制作了一个完整的网站，关于她两岁时去世的孩子，她有一个小小的、你知道，蜡烛GIF，背景里播放着一首小小的MIDI歌曲，这就是她的故事。杰森想确保像GeoCities这样的网站及其数据不会就这样被抹去。所以我们联系了一群志同道合的数字保存爱好者，他们散布在世界各地，他们起草了一个计划。应该有人介入，应该有一个“A小队”，一个冲进去制作副本的档案小队。那不是很好吗？所以我们宣布我们是档案小队。
We're going to rescue your s**t, and that was our slogan. We're going to rescue your s** and that was our slogan. We're gonna rescue your sh**. Archive team decided their mission was to keep an eye out for websites in danger of being shut down. The ones that they say are on Death Watch and download every piece of data they could before that site goes dark. Their goal is to preserve digital heritage no matter how small. In their first project, geosities. For us it was worth it because we hate Yahoo. But it wasn't solely about saying up yours to Yahoo. Yahoo!
我们要拯救你们的垃圾，这就是我们的口号。我们要拯救你们的垃圾，这就是我们的口号。我们要拯救你们的垃圾。档案小队决定他们的使命是留意那些面临关闭危险的网站。那些他们称之为“死亡观察”的网站，并在该网站变暗之前下载他们能下载的每一条数据。他们的目标是保护数字遗产，无论它有多小。他们的第一个项目：GeoCities。对我们来说，这很值得，因为我们讨厌雅虎。但这不仅仅是为了对雅虎说“去你的”。雅虎！
Okay, well that was a very big part of it, but it was also about something bigger. I also wanted people to kind of get knocked in the head about the impermanence of digital information, that it was both brittle and easily lost, but also with a little bit of care, easily saved and kept. Archive team had a dual mission. In addition to preserving things, they also want us to understand that digital information is fragile. The profiles you build on any social media site, the videos you upload to YouTube, they all exist out of
好吧，那确实是很大一部分原因，但它也关乎更宏大的东西。我还想让人们意识到数字信息的无常性，它既脆弱又容易丢失，但只要稍微用心，也很容易保存和保留。档案小队有双重使命。除了保存东西，他们还想让我们明白数字信息是脆弱的。你在任何社交媒体网站上建立的个人资料，你上传到YouTube的视频，它们都存在于
your hands and on some corporation servers, and they can vanish at any given moment. They have no idea that it can literally, literally disappear in a week or a day, and it just come to it and there's an error and it's gone, and I get to see that over and over and over again. So that's, you know, I'm delighted that they're making these worlds, and I'm cynical about how long they last. Yahoo! had hinted in early 2009 that it would be closing down the service sometime later that year, so geocities could have maybe a few months or a few days. Archive team got to work immediately trying to recruit as many people as possible to help with what Jason referred to as geocities download a pollusa. I started using whatever social media capital I had at the time, and about 200, I think
你的掌控之外，在某些公司的服务器上，它们随时可能消失。他们根本不知道它真的、真的可能在一周或一天内消失，你只是点开它，然后出现一个错误，它就没了，我一次又一次地看到这种情况。所以，你知道，我很高兴他们在创造这些世界，但我对它们能持续多久持怀疑态度。雅虎在2009年初暗示它将在那年晚些时候关闭该服务，所以GeoCities可能还有几个月或几天的时间。档案小队立即开始工作，试图招募尽可能多的人来帮助杰森所说的“GeoCities下载狂欢”。我开始利用我当时拥有的任何社交媒体资本，大约200人，我想
300 people in total came in, and it was really lumpy. They had their computers crawling Yahoo servers to pull out any piece of public Geo City's data they could get. And we were just doing it day in and day out and saying, okay, who wants to take this part over, who wants to do this part? Let's look for this. Let's do searches on the web for every noun in the dictionary. Try to find every Geoity site that mentions any noun,
总共300人加入了，而且非常零散。他们让他们的电脑爬取雅虎服务器，以提取他们能得到的任何公共GeoCities数据。我们日复一日地做着这件事，说，好吧，谁想接手这部分，谁想做那部分？让我们找找这个。让我们在网上搜索字典里的每一个名词。试着找到每一个提到任何名词的GeoCities网站，
and then try to compile them into a unique set and then assign it to people to download. Then, on October 26, 2009, after six months of work, the day they all dreaded finally came. Archive team watched from their respective computers as the digital city slowly went offline for good. Jason said that watching Yahoo pull the plug was like something out of 2001 a space odyssey. It is exactly like shutting down how. And we will be like this set has gone down. They've now powered down this server. They've now powered down this server. Archive team was still working as fast as possible to grab whatever geosities data was left, while the servers went dark one by one. Well, like, here it goes.
然后试着把它们汇编成一个独特的集合，然后分配给人们去下载。然后，在2009年10月26日，经过六个月的工作，他们最害怕的那一天终于来了。档案小队在各自的电脑前看着这个数字城市慢慢永久下线。杰森说，看着雅虎拔掉插头就像《2001太空漫游》里的情节。这完全就像关闭“哈尔”（HAL）。我们会说这个站点已经下线了。他们现在已经关闭了这个服务器。他们现在已经关闭了这个服务器。档案小队仍在尽可能快地工作，以抓取剩下的任何GeoCities数据，而服务器一个接一个地变暗。好吧，就像，它要走了。
We just lost this one. We just lost this one. Keep going, keep going. And we're just going until finally it's just not responding meaningfully at all. I mean, that's pretty much the ending of every one of these stories. It's us packing up the boxes, putting them on the pallets. You know, so it's this pride that we got the job done, but it really feels like we lifted a piano up 20 stories
我们刚刚失去了这个。我们刚刚失去了这个。继续，继续。我们只是不停地工作，直到最后它根本没有任何有意义的响应。我的意思是，这几乎是每一个故事的结局。是我们打包箱子，把它们放在托盘上。你知道，所以这是一种自豪感，我们完成了工作，但感觉就像我们把一架钢琴抬上20层楼，
and then took it down again, you know, 20 minutes later. Like, yep, we were good piano movers. But it wasn't all for nothing. In the end, archiveive Team managed to extract a terabyte of data from geosities. And as it turns out, there were multiple parallel projects that were downloading geosities data. A lot of them have sent their data to Jason for safe keeping. Altogether, Archive Team saved more than a million accounts from Joletion. Archive Team wanted to bring some attention to their work, so they took all of that
然后20分钟后又把它搬下来。就像，是的，我们是优秀的钢琴搬运工。但这并非徒劳。最终，档案小队成功地从GeoCities提取了一TB的数据。事实证明，有多个平行项目在下载GeoCities数据。他们中的许多人把数据发给了杰森保管。总共，档案小队从湮灭中拯救了超过一百万个账户。档案小队想让人们关注他们的工作，所以他们拿走了所有
Geocities data they'd preserved, and they turned it into a torrent on the pirate bay. The pirate bay is generally used for illegally downloading games, movies, and software, so no one really saw this coming. You're like, we have the hottest new where for you. Here's GeoCities. And it was the largest torrent at its time. It broke everything. And when it got uncompressed, it turned out Windows machines couldn't handle it. People were furious because it's terrible. Like, why am I doing this? It's telling me I have, you know, 19 months to download.
他们保存的GeoCities数据，并把它做成了一个海盗湾（The Pirate Bay）上的种子。海盗湾通常用于非法下载游戏、电影和软件，所以没人预料到这一点。你就像，我们有最热门的新东西给你们。这是GeoCities。它是当时最大的种子。它破坏了一切。当它被解压时，结果发现Windows机器无法处理它。人们很愤怒，因为这太糟糕了。就像，我为什么要这么做？它告诉我，你知道，我有19个月的时间来下载。
Surely it's some sort of top secret, you know, allocation of information of the darkest parts of the web. And it's like, no, it's cats. And it's lots of rock, been rolled, fan sites. And it's families telling you that they're going to have a barbecue. Jason wasn't sure what people would actually do with the Geo City's data, but that really
肯定是什么绝密的信息分配，关于网络最黑暗的部分。结果是，不，全是猫。还有很多“瑞克摇”（Rick Roll）粉丝网站。还有家庭告诉你他们要举行烧烤。杰森不确定人们会用GeoCities数据做什么，但这真的
wasn't his concern. He just wanted to make sure that it was safe and available to anyone who wanted it, and maybe, if he was lucky, something useful would come out of it down the line. I long to go got out of the argument of what good is this. Actually, a number of people have downloaded the Geosities Torrent and have made some really cool projects with that data. A good amount of Geosities pages have been restored and you can browse through them online.
不是他关心的。他只是想确保它是安全的，并且对任何想要它的人可用，也许，如果他幸运的话，未来会有一些有用的东西从中产生。我很久以前就摆脱了“这有什么用”的争论。事实上，很多人下载了GeoCities种子，并用这些数据制作了一些非常酷的项目。相当多的GeoCities页面已经恢复，你可以在线浏览它们。
Since saving Geosities, Jason and the archive team have preserved a number of dying websites around the internet, from Yahoo groups to Justin.tv. It's all accessible on a digital archive called Wayback Machine, where you can find over 477 billion saved web pages. The Wayback Machine was founded by the internet archive, where Jason Scott is now an archivist. A lot of time and energy went into rescuing geocities,
自从拯救了GeoCities，杰森和档案小队已经保存了互联网上许多垂死的网站，从雅虎群组到Justin.tv。这一切都可以在一个名为“Wayback Machine”（时光机）的数字档案中访问，在那里你可以找到超过4770亿个保存的网页。Wayback Machine由互联网档案（Internet Archive）创立，杰森·斯科特现在是那里的档案管理员。很多时间和精力都花在了拯救GeoCities上，
along with a ton of other archaic sites from this generation of the web. But I want to be clear, none of this was salvaged as examples of how well the web worked back in the day. No one needs more net scape now buttons, or Backstreet Boys fan pages. I think we're good on Backstreet Boys fan pages. The point is, these archives should be studied, because our web history is our history, no matter how goofy it might appear.
以及这一代网络中的大量其他古老网站。但我想要明确一点，这些都不是作为网络过去运作得有多好的例子而被挽救的。现在没人需要更多的Netscape“导航”按钮，或者后街男孩的粉丝页面。我想我们已经有足够的后街男孩粉丝页面了。重点是，这些档案应该被研究，因为我们的网络历史就是我们的历史，无论它看起来多么滑稽。
If the internet's history were sketched to look like the march of progress, that famous illustration charting human evolution with an ape on one side and a man on the other, geosities would be like that third guy from the right, a little hairy, a little clumsy, but definitely an important link that made us what we are today. I mean, it's not necessarily art, but it's absolutely culture. James Crawford again.
如果互联网的历史被勾勒成“进步的行进”，那幅著名的图表描绘了人类进化，一边是猿猴，另一边是人，GeoCities就像从右边数第三个家伙，有点多毛，有点笨拙，但绝对是让我们成为今天这个样子的重要环节。我的意思是，它不一定是艺术，但它绝对是文化。还是詹姆斯·克劳福德。
You know, this is what we've all was done, as humans, you know, going back to the earliest marks we put on the caves, is you're presented with a surface and what do you do with it? How do you mark it? How do you represent who you are on that space? And, you know, a number of people have made this comparison between the kind of cave paintings of last goal and what was happening on geocities. And it seems like a bizarre, almost absurd comparison to make.
你知道，这就是我们人类一直以来所做的，追溯到我们在洞穴上留下的最早痕迹，你面对一个表面，你会用它做什么？你如何标记它？你如何在这个空间里代表你是谁？而且，你知道，很多人把拉斯科洞穴壁画和GeoCities上发生的事情进行了比较。这看起来是一个离奇的、几乎荒谬的比较。
But actually, if we fast forward another 10,000 years and look back, that's absolutely what it was. It was people grappling with a new technology and how to represent their humanity in that space. You can imagine thousands of years from now. Pass the boundary of the cringey recent past to a future human, dusting off an old PC desktop from 1997, finding a geocities torrent, and taking an anthropological exploration of what's inside.
但实际上，如果我们再快进一万年回头看，那绝对就是它。这是人们在与一种新技术搏斗，以及如何在该空间中代表他们的人性。你可以想象几千年后。越过令人尴尬的近期过去，未来的某个人，掸掉1997年的旧PC桌面上的灰尘，找到一个GeoCities种子，并对里面的内容进行人类学探索。
So the first thing they're going to do is just waste a week trying to figure out if they're getting the colors wrong. Like they're going to look at these backgrounds, and they're gonna be like, this is objectively illegible, and they're gonna check the specs, check the specs, and go, nope! Those people had no taste! What was going on there? And the answer was, the sky was the limit.
所以他们要做的第一件事就是浪费一周时间试图弄清楚他们是不是把颜色搞错了。就像他们会看着这些背景，然后会说，这客观上是无法辨认的，他们会检查规格，检查规格，然后说，不！那些人根本没品味！那里发生了什么？答案是，天空才是极限。
So, why not? Yellow on pink. Why not? Blinking text saying that this is your homepage and then an animated gif with three frames of a waving care bear right next to your description of, you know, love for Jesus. This future person is going to discover a tiny window of web history, where people were trying their best to chart a course through completely unknown territory. Where users took chances and weren't ashamed
所以，为什么不呢？粉色上的黄色。为什么不呢？闪烁的文字说这是你的主页，然后旁边是一个动画GIF，有三帧挥手的爱心熊，紧挨着你对，你知道，对耶稣的爱的描述。这个未来的人将发现网络历史的一个微小窗口，人们正在尽最大努力在完全未知的领域中规划路线。用户冒险尝试，并不羞于
to look a little messy or garish or hopeful. They're gonna see this boundless joy of people who are unfettered by feeling that they have to sell themselves to present their best faces. And they'll see a lot of lies, a lot of truth, a lot of honesty, but it's gonna come from a person talking to you. Because geosities made it easy to work in the code of the web, but it didn't teach you
看起来有点凌乱、花哨或充满希望。他们会看到人们那种无限的快乐，他们不受必须推销自己以展示最好一面的感觉的束缚。他们会看到很多谎言，很多真相，很多诚实，但它将来自一个正在和你交谈的人。因为GeoCities让你很容易使用网络代码，但它并没有教你
to be a performer. So that's what they're going to find, and they're not going to believe it. They're going to assume this was all a trick. Nobody could be this nice. Nobody could be this forward. No one could be this personal, but they were. We have another story about a different virtual apocalypse after the break. So we're back with Vivian who brought us that story about geocities. Hey Viv. Hello, how are you?
成为一个表演者。所以这就是他们会发现的东西，他们不会相信。他们会认为这全是骗局。没人能这么好。没人能这么直率。没人能这么个人化，但他们确实做到了。休息后，我们还有另一个关于不同虚拟世界末日的故事。所以我们回到薇薇安身边，她给我们带来了那个关于GeoCities的故事。嘿，薇薇。你好，你好吗？
I'm good. I'm good. So one of the reasons why we do these code is we have all this stuff that's on the cutting room floor that doesn't quite fit into the story, but it's so good that we just want to talk about it. So let's talk about it. So something that we kind of alluded to in the main piece, but didn't really spend a lot of time getting into was the afterlife of the GeoCity's data that was saved by archive team. Right. So we kind of focused on like the life, death, and preservation of GeoCity's, but we didn't
我很好。我很好。所以我们做这些节目的原因之一是，我们有所有这些被剪掉的素材，它们不太适合故事，但它们太好了，我们只想谈谈。所以让我们谈谈吧。所以我们在主片中提到了一些，但没有花太多时间深入探讨的事情，是档案小队保存的GeoCities数据的来世。对。所以我们有点专注于GeoCities的生、死和保存，但我们没有
really dip into what people have done with it afterwards because the story kind of felt complete on its own, but there's a lot there. Right. So what are people making with this, Joe, cities data? So probably one of my favorite projects is this website called camminsworld.net, which was created by this web designer named Cameron Askin. And I don't really know how to describe it other than saying it's like, it's like everything that the Space Jam website wishes it was.
真正深入探讨人们之后用它做了什么，因为故事本身感觉很完整，但那里有很多东西。对。那么人们用这些GeoCities数据制作了什么？所以可能我最喜欢的项目之一是这个叫camminsworld.net的网站，它是由一位名叫卡梅伦·阿斯金的网页设计师创建的。我真的不知道怎么形容它，只能说它就像，它就像《空中大灌篮》（Space Jam）网站希望成为的一切。
Like I don't even, like I really don't know how to explain it, but it's just a really cool way to kind of click through and view old geocities pages. And like there's this theme song that loops around that's been playing in my head for like the last two months. Like it's great, so you should definitely look at it. Another website that's worth checking out is called deletedcity.net, which is this awesome,
就像我甚至，就像我真的不知道怎么解释，但它只是点击浏览旧GeoCities页面的一种非常酷的方式。而且，你知道，有一首循环播放的主题曲，在过去两个月里一直在我脑海里回荡。就像它很棒，所以你一定要看看。另一个值得一看的网站叫deletedcity.net，这是一个很棒的，
like interactive map created by a designer named Richard Vigen, where you could browse through the geosities neighborhoods as if they're neighborhoods on a city grid. So it's really cool to be able to zoom in and see it. If it were an actual city, this is what it would look like. That's cool. That's cool. But one project that I really want to talk about is called One Terabyte of the Killabite Age. And it was created by two people named Oliya Liyalina and Dregan Espenshid. And it's an archive of almost 400,000 Geosities pages.
像交互式地图，由一位名叫理查德·维根的设计师创建，你可以在那里浏览GeoCities社区，就像它们是城市网格上的社区一样。所以能够放大并看到它真的很酷。如果它是一个真正的城市，它看起来就是这样。那很酷。那很酷。但我真正想谈的一个项目叫“一TB的千字节时代”（One Terabyte of the Kilobyte Age）。它是由两个名叫奥莉娅·利亚琳娜和德拉甘·埃斯彭希德的人创建的。它是近40万个GeoCities页面的档案。
And I originally spoke with Oliya for the piece because she had this really interesting relationship with Geosities and the old web because she was a webmaster and web design professor back in like the mid 90s. And she told me that she used to save web pages like the ones in geocities so she could show her students examples of like how not to build a good web page. Like don't use like twinkling star backgrounds or a million of the colors or those under construction signs that are never taken off. Yeah, yeah, like don't do this.
我最初为这个节目采访了奥莉娅，因为她与GeoCities和旧网络有着非常有趣的联系，因为她在90年代中期是一位站长和网页设计教授。她告诉我，她过去常常保存像GeoCities那样的网页，这样她就可以向学生展示如何“不”建立一个好网页的例子。比如不要使用闪烁的星星背景，或者一百万种颜色，或者那些永远不会被拿掉的“施工中”标志。是的，是的，就像不要这样做。
I see. But you know, she said that she was noticing the shift from, you know, web 1.0 to web 2.0 in real time towards the end of the late 90s in the beginning of the early 2000s because it was getting a lot harder for her to find like the twinkling star backgrounds or the welcome to my homepage chips. You mean homepage gifs? Yes, homepage gifs. Like, we're not going to start this right now. Okay, keep going.
我明白了。但你知道，她说她实时注意到了从Web 1.0到Web 2.0的转变，在90年代末和21世纪初，因为她发现像闪烁的星星背景或“欢迎来到我的主页”GIF变得越来越难了。你是说主页GIF？是的，主页GIF。就像，我们现在不开始这个。好吧，继续。
But like, you know, because she started seeing that they're like disappearing, she really started to study these things and like really love the design of the early web because of what it represented. Because of very pragmatic reasons, I started to collect them just in all safe graphics. And it was not because I thought at the time that you should archive the web, or you can have some historic significance.
但就像，你知道，因为她开始看到它们正在消失，她真的开始研究这些东西，并因为它们所代表的意义而真正爱上了早期网络的设计。出于非常务实的原因，我开始收集它们，只是为了保存图形。并不是因为我当时认为你应该存档网络，或者它有什么历史意义。
But then I realized that it's not just some funny websites that disappear, but visions of how the worldwide web should be. They are getting changed. So when the GeoCity's TORN got released on the Pirate Bay, Oli and Dragan like immediately downloaded it and have been studying it ever since. But what I really like about the work that they're doing is that this is not a nostalgic exercise. They're really looking at what these early web elements can teach us about our relationship with the web in the 90s and early 2000s. Like if you look at something like the under construction sign for example. On the construction sign it's not just a
但我意识到，消失的不仅仅是一些有趣的网站，而是关于万维网应该是什么样的愿景。它们正在被改变。所以当GeoCities种子在海盗湾发布时，奥莉娅和德拉甘立即下载了它，并从那时起一直在研究它。但我真正喜欢他们所做的工作的是，这不是一种怀旧练习。他们真的在研究这些早期网络元素能教给我们关于我们在90年代和21世纪初与网络的关系。比如，如果你看看像“施工中”标志这样的东西。施工标志不仅仅是一个
far near picture. It's not just a symbol for the old website but I tried to explain what does it mean exactly? Why is it important? So basically, the under construction sign was a symbol for this moment when the web was being hand-built by amateur users. And there was this general acceptance that a website could be a work in progress. Like, you could take your time, and it was okay for people
远近图片。它不仅仅是旧网站的一个符号，但我试图解释它到底意味着什么？为什么它很重要？基本上，“施工中”标志代表了网络由业余用户手工构建的那个时刻。当时人们普遍接受网站可以是一个正在进行中的作品。就像你可以慢慢来，人们也乐于在网站完成前先睹为快。
to get a glimpse of the building process before it was finished. But that all changed with the introduction of Web 2.0 because more professional web designers were taking over and big social networking sites were taking over. On the construction sign was really the first one that professional designers started to remove from their website because,
但随着Web 2.0的引入，这一切都改变了，因为更专业的网页设计师接管了网站，大型社交网站也随之兴起。“施工中”标志确实是专业设计师开始从网站上移除的第一个元素，因为，
oh, how can it be that something is not ready? I never thought about that before, like the disappearance of the under construction sign, really a signal that's not to read you. Huh. I never thought about that before. Like the disappearance of the under construction sign, really signaled this move towards a kind of corporate version of the internet. Yeah, that's what Oli believes. And like, this is just a one aspect of how GeoCities is being studied.
哦，怎么会有东西还没准备好呢？我以前从未想过这一点，比如“施工中”标志的消失，确实是一个信号，表明它不再是未完成的。嗯。我以前从未想过这一点。比如“施工中”标志的消失，确实标志着向一种企业版互联网的转变。是的，奥利就是这么认为的。而且，这只是GeoCities被研究的一个方面。
But I thought this was cool because projects like this basically show that it's possible to apply some sort of like archeological lens to this website that a lot of people wrote off is useless. Yeah, I mean, it totally makes sense to me. I mean, that you would tell us what we were thinking at the time that you needed to put up a site so badly, like within 10 minutes that you had to put an under construction sign on there. But you might take with it or you might just leave it, you know, like, we're not. Yeah, I actually, I'm the carest, at this time who cared. Yeah, why not?
但我认为这很酷，因为像这样的项目基本上表明，对这个被许多人认为毫无用处的网站应用某种考古视角是可能的。是的，我的意思是，这对我来说完全说得通。我的意思是，你会告诉我们当时我们在想什么，以至于你需要如此迫切地建立一个网站，比如在10分钟内，你不得不放上一个“施工中”标志。但你可能会随手处理，或者你可能只是把它留在那里，你知道，就像，我们不是。是的，实际上，我是那个关心的人，当时谁在乎呢。是的，为什么不呢？
So tell me her project's name again. So it's called one terabyte of the kilobite age. That's such a good name. I love it. I mean, people should definitely check that out because I mean, it's like, they'll have a whole new appreciation for under construction signs. And what we think of is ugly graphics that really made the wetwood is today. Yes, exactly.
所以再告诉我一遍她项目的名字。它叫“千字节时代的1TB”。这名字真好。我喜欢它。我的意思是，人们绝对应该去看看，因为我的意思是，他们会对“施工中”标志有全新的认识。以及我们认为丑陋的图形，正是它们造就了今天的网络。是的，完全正确。
The whole time that we were putting this piece together, I was reminded of this story that I did originally for Stomp Judgment, but we played it on 9 MPI before about the destruction of an online community, which was also a really sad story in many ways. And so I wanted to just like attach it here to play it for you. So you can do it. Yay! I love the story. Here it is. A few months before the end of the world, Paul Monaco posted this message on YouTube.
在我们制作这段节目的整个过程中，我想起了我最初为《Stomp Judgment》制作的一个故事，但我们之前在99% Invisible上播放过，关于一个在线社区的毁灭，在很多方面这也是一个非常悲伤的故事。所以我只是想把它附在这里播放给你听。所以你可以做到了。耶！我喜欢这个故事。这就是它。在世界末日的前几个月，保罗·莫纳科在YouTube上发布了这条消息。
Hello, everyone. Paul Monaco here. Buddha Paul is most of you know me as um you probably all heard the news, Ye land, the Simpson line closing down. The world that was ending was called The Sims Online. It was an online version of one of the most popular computer games ever made. You've all been wonderful, you helped me through a hard time in my life when I first got online. games ever made. But ironically, the online version of The Sims was not very popular. They ended up losing tons of subscribers and changing the name to EA Land, and then they finally pulled the plug. Let's try to stay in touch. And it's not to go back with whatever you choose to do and move on to.
大家好。我是保罗·莫纳科。你们大多数人称我为佛系保罗，嗯，你们可能都听到了新闻，EA Land，Sims Online要关闭了。那个即将终结的世界叫做《模拟人生在线》。它是史上最受欢迎的电脑游戏之一的在线版本。你们都太棒了，当我刚上网时，你们帮我度过了人生中的一段艰难时期。史上最受欢迎的游戏。但讽刺的是，《模拟人生》的在线版本并不太受欢迎。他们最终失去了大量的订阅者，并将名字改为EA Land，最后他们终于拔掉了插头。让我们保持联系。无论你选择做什么，都不要回头，继续前进。
As you can probably hear, EA Land is not a normal video game. There are no monsters, no killing. And although it had some competitive elements, for many players competition doesn't the point at all. Unlike a lot of other games where you might be shooting people or slaying dragons or something, this was a game about socializing. That's Robert Ashley. I'm Robert Ashley. He produces a very popular and fantastic internet radio show that's been on a very long hiatus. I'm the creator of a life well wasted. A life well wasted.
正如你可能听到的，EA Land不是一款普通的游戏。没有怪物，没有杀戮。虽然它有一些竞争元素，但对许多玩家来说，竞争根本不是重点。不像许多其他游戏，你可能会射击人或屠龙之类的，这是一个关于社交的游戏。那是罗伯特·阿什利。我是罗伯特·阿什利。他制作了一个非常受欢迎且精彩的互联网广播节目，该节目已经停播了很长时间。我是《A Life Well Wasted》的创作者。《A Life Well Wasted》。
It's about video games and the people who love them. And EA Land was a video game that a dedicated few absolutely loved. The crowd that attracted, I think, were people who just wanted to get together and sort of chat, meet strangers. It was a nice place. Over time, it became a kind of intimate, almost bar,
它是关于电子游戏和热爱它们的人。而EA Land是一款被少数忠实玩家绝对喜爱的电子游戏。我认为它吸引的人群只是想聚在一起聊天、结识陌生人。那是一个不错的地方。随着时间的推移，它变成了一种亲密的、几乎像酒吧一样的地方，
like the cheers of video games, where everyone knows your name. And at the moment that Paul Monaco, aka Buddha Paul, found EA Land, it was exactly what he needed most. My wife had a long-term illness. From a blood transfusion she had hepatitis C. And the last three years or so of her life were pretty, pretty much a blood transfusion she had hepatitis C. And the last three years or so in her life were pretty, pretty much a challenge for her. Well, for both of us. And after she passed away, I had absolutely no function of then to wake up, go to work, and go to sleep again. With her illness, I didn't get out of socialized much. We weren't able to go out to the bars and meet up with
就像电子游戏里的《干杯酒吧》，每个人都知道你的名字。而在保罗·莫纳科，也就是佛系保罗，发现EA Land的那一刻，这正是他最需要的。我的妻子患有长期疾病。因为一次输血，她患上了丙型肝炎。她生命中最后三年左右的时间，对我俩来说都是一个巨大的挑战。在她去世后，我完全失去了生活的动力，除了醒来、去工作、然后再去睡觉。因为她的病，我没有出去社交太多。我们无法去酒吧和朋友见面，
friends and have dinner. I totally be socialized myself. And this game was kind of a way for me to just kind of get back into living again. It was pretty amazing. In Paul began to live for E.A. Land. He would play it for hours and hours. It was the first thing he did when he got home from work. You treated to a big warm greeting everyone would say hi and you know your I.M.s would be beeping along and you'd be hitting it with that. It made you feel really good. It wasn't the real world, but his friends were real friends. In virtual worlds, do have an upside. You're a race, you're a college religion, all that can be totally masked, and you're truly judged on who you really are
一起吃晚餐。我完全把自己与社会隔绝了。而这个游戏是我重新开始生活的一种方式。这太神奇了。保罗开始为EA Land而活。他会玩上好几个小时。这是他下班回家后做的第一件事。你会得到一个热情的问候，每个人都会说嗨，你知道你的即时通讯工具会发出哔哔声，你会回应它。这让你感觉非常好。这不是现实世界，但他的朋友是真实的朋友。在虚拟世界里，确实有优势。你的种族、你的大学、宗教，所有这些都可以被完全掩盖，你真正被评判的是你真实的样子，
and how you present yourself. There's no prejudice, there's no preconceived anything. It's just, you're really taking that face value. People could really like break loose and be themselves and have some fun. It just feels really good. But Paul's Utopia didn't last because E.A.L.A. and started hemorrhaging money. The writing was on the wall, the server was about to go dark, and this event, this virtual
以及你如何展示自己。没有偏见，没有先入为主的任何东西。你只是被真正地按面值对待。人们真的可以释放自我，做回自己，享受乐趣。这感觉真好。但保罗的乌托邦并没有持续下去，因为EA Land开始亏损。大势已去，服务器即将变黑，而这次事件，这次虚拟的
apocalypse, might only exist in the memory of the players, if it weren't for Dr. Henry Lowwood. I had just stumbled across this project by Henry Lowwood. My name is Henry Lowwood, who is this archival researcher at Stanford. And I had a project called How They Got Game, which is on the history of digital games and simulations. Saving video games for future generation. You know, 50, 100, 200 years from now. How are we going to save that history? You know, like we've got to save the video games for future generation, you know 50 100 200 years from now How are we gonna save that history you know like we've got to save the video games
末日，可能只会存在于玩家的记忆中，如果不是因为亨利·洛伍德博士的话。我偶然发现了亨利·洛伍德的这个项目。我叫亨利·洛伍德，是斯坦福大学的一名档案研究员。我有一个项目叫“他们是如何获得游戏的”，是关于数字游戏和模拟的历史。为后代保存电子游戏。你知道，50年、100年、200年后。我们将如何保存那段历史？你知道，我们必须为后代保存电子游戏，你知道50年、100年、200年后，我们将如何保存那段历史，你知道，我们必须保存电子游戏
So dr. Loewood in his colleagues preserve what happens inside video games now for a single player game like Pac-Man For example, this is easy you effectively take out the Atari cartridge and put it on the shelf But saving multiplayer online games is not so simple. Saving the software alone is kind of a barren exercise. If you save the code for Eiland and turn it on 100 years from now, you'd enter a world and nothing would be there. All the things that Paul Monagone's friends love would be impossible to find.
所以洛伍德博士和他的同事们现在保存着电子游戏内部发生的事情。例如，对于像《吃豆人》这样的单人游戏，这很容易，你只需取出雅达利卡带并把它放在架子上。但保存多人在线游戏并不那么简单。仅仅保存软件是一种贫瘠的做法。如果你保存了EA Land的代码并在100年后打开它，你会进入一个世界，而那里什么都没有。保罗·莫纳科的朋友们所喜爱的一切都将无法找到。
You need to document what people are doing in these faces. That situation is much more like what a historian on archivists would do when faced with the problem of documenting the real world. To see what it would be like when an online world came to an end. What happens when a virtual world closes? The end of a culture. What is it like to be there in the last minute and when it shuts down? So the tape is rolling in the last few hours
你需要记录人们在这些空间里做的事情。这种情况更像是一位历史学家或档案管理员在面对记录现实世界的问题时所做的事情。看看当一个在线世界终结时会是什么样子。当一个虚拟世界关闭时会发生什么？一种文化的终结。在最后一分钟身处其中并关闭时是什么感觉？所以磁带在最后几个小时里一直在滚动，
via land or being recorded. And the most dedicated die hard users are there, exchanging virtual hugs and reminiscing. The players are typing messages that appear like comic book word bubbles. You hear all these avatars cry. And you also hear all the coos and moans and the gibberish language of the game known as simlish.
EA Land正在被记录。最忠实的铁杆用户都在那里，交换虚拟拥抱并回忆往事。玩家们正在输入像漫画书气泡一样出现的消息。你听到所有这些化身在哭泣。你还会听到所有的咕咕声、呻吟声以及被称为“模拟语”的游戏乱码语言。
And you know, they sound like they're gonna be bummed and everything, but it's not like a big pity party. But then toward the end of the night, there's this radio station that you can listen to in the game called Charmed Radio. And they had this DJ there named Spike. He is sort of the only voice that you went appearing at the end of the world. And as soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. soon as he starts talking, you understand what is being lost. I can't stress enough how much you guys have been to me over the past however many years it's been. Really has been awesome ad.
你知道，他们听起来会很沮丧，但这不像是一场大型的同情派对。但在深夜临近时，游戏里有一个你可以收听的广播电台，叫“魅力电台”。他们那里有一位名叫斯派克的DJ。他算是你在世界末日出现时听到的唯一声音。一旦他开始说话，你就明白失去了什么。一旦他开始说话，你就明白失去了什么。我怎么强调都不为过，过去这些年来你们对我意味着什么。这真的很棒。
Some people don't get attached to things, but when you make friends, I look people living in this game. It's actually really hard. So, I'm going to play the last song. It's Sarah Brightman and Andrea Bacheli. Time to say goodbye. Hopefully you guys will like. It's been such a long time. My Yahoo ID is 1,345.
有些人不会对事物产生依恋，但当你结交朋友，看着人们生活在这个游戏中时。这实际上真的很难。所以，我要播放最后一首歌。是莎拉·布莱曼和安德烈·波切利的《告别时刻》。希望你们会喜欢。已经过去很长时间了。我的雅虎ID是1345。
D-*** Anyway, 1,345. You're lucky to like everybody and best wishes. I love you all and it's been great knowing you. Take care guys and let's just, I just want to, even if you haven't got a drink, propose a toast to Parasad, who's been absolutely amazing. Parasad, we can have done this for that.
D-*** 不管怎样，1345。祝大家好运，最美好的祝愿。我爱你们所有人，认识你们真是太好了。保重，伙计们，让我们，我只是想，即使你没有喝的，也为Parasad举杯，他一直非常棒。Parasad，没有你我们做不到。
Thank you. I can have done this without you. Thank you. You get this feeling like being on the deck of the Titanic. Anyone who actually stayed to begin was very much invested in the game on an emotional level. When they pulled the plug on the server, bits and pieces of the world started disappearing. The environment began to disintegrate. The texture on the trees flickered, and all the people froze, in blanked out of existence.
谢谢。没有你我做不到。谢谢。你会有种像在泰坦尼克号甲板上的感觉。任何真正坚持到最后的人都在情感层面上对游戏投入了极大的感情。当他们拔掉服务器插头时，世界的碎片开始消失。环境开始瓦解。树木上的纹理闪烁，所有人都冻结了，并从存在中消失。
The actual ending was, you know, not with a bang, with a whimper. And the last thing that they saw was basically just an error message, a server disconnect message. And then, the world ended. That story was originally produced for the great public radio show Snap Judgment in 2010. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Leigh, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by Sean Riel. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colessted is the digital director. The rest of the team is Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Chris Baroube,
实际的结局，你知道，不是一声巨响，而是一声呜咽。他们看到的最后一件事基本上只是一个错误消息，一个服务器断开连接的消息。然后，世界终结了。那个故事最初是为2010年的伟大公共广播节目《Snap Judgment》制作的。本周的《99% Invisible》由薇薇安·李制作，布莱森·巴恩斯混音，肖恩·里尔配乐。我们的高级制片人是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员是克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯·巴鲁贝、
Joe Rosenberg, Katie Mingle, Abbey Madonna, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster Rooster buildings, geosities is just one small section of that book. There are a ton of other fascinating stories about lost and ruined buildings. We'll have a link to that as well. We are a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which lives at various places all over North America, but is centered in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world, by them all, at radiotopia.fm.
乔·罗森伯格、凯蒂·明格尔、艾比·麦当娜、索菲亚·克拉茨克，还有我，罗曼·马斯。建筑，GeoCities只是那本书的一小部分。还有很多关于丢失和废弃建筑的迷人故事。我们也会提供相关链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，它存在于北美各地的不同地方，但中心位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的RadioTopia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立集体，在radiotopia.fm上购买它们。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and show at 99pi.org, or on Instagram and read it too. You can now order the New York Times bestseller, the 99% invisible silly, at 99PI.org slash book of links to purchase it everywhere that you get books, including signed editions from Barnes & Noble, and at various indie bookstores from the country, links to the audiobook, and if you got the book and enjoyed it, review it somewhere. It's a huge boost to us.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi.org，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注。你现在可以在99PI.org/book订购《纽约时报》畅销书《99% Invisible City》，链接可以在你购买书籍的任何地方找到，包括巴诺书店的签名版，以及全国各地的各种独立书店，还有有声读物的链接，如果你买了这本书并喜欢它，请在某处写下评论。这对我们有巨大的帮助。
Also, if you see it out on display at your local bookstore, tweet me a picture. I usually retweet those because it's fun to see them out in the world. For all your other 99PI needs, look no further than 99PI.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
另外，如果你在当地书店看到它在展示，请发推特给我一张照片。我通常会转发这些照片，因为看到它们出现在世界上很有趣。关于你所有其他的99PI需求，请访问99PI.org。Radio Topia。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。